I was raising these kids I didn't have
any money for those of you who've raised
kids with no money sometimes you have to
find places that you can take them for
free right and Ikea we used to play hide
and seek in that place
I was like stay in the home department
and everybody go yeah and you know you
know what he used to tell us he used to
take us to toy stores and say look this
is called a toy store you don't get to
take anything out of it you get to go up
take everything out of the box play with
it in the aisle and then put it back in
the box and relief that was what the toy
store was to me when I was a kid do you
know what else I didn't think you could
take anything I think you could buy
anything I just played with the toys in
the store because I didn't want them to
think that we could leave with anything
so
I never asked to buy a toy ever do you
know what else I couldn't afford uh
amusement parks so I would find I would
find an empty parking lot at night and I
would put them in the trunk of my car
and I would just drive around real fast
bro it hit speed bumps at like 30 miles
an hour we were like this is great yeah
I but I did realize I'm like maybe the
exhaust they might have been in that
trunk for a little too long I feel like
they started getting out like yeah I
don't feel like I don't feel like that
was the exhaust I feel like it was the
concussions yeah it could have been
being off of each other